so we have this exponential equation you
can see what is an exponential equation
it's where we have that variable in the
exponent what you can do with these
problems is if you can get the basis to
be the same then all we have to do is
set the exponents equal and solve so
when we look at nine and we look at
127th is there a number that we can
write both of those bases in terms of
well nine in 27 I notice they're both
like three as a common base so what I
can do is I can say nine is really like
three squared okay so I'm placing nine
with three squared still raised to the X
plus one power
127th is really like three to the
negative third power because three cubed
is 27 the negative exponent you take the
reciprocal also still raised to the
negative two x plus three power but what
do you do when you have a power raised
to a another power an exponent raised to
another exponent you multiply those
exponents here you have to be careful
you're gonna have to distribute the two
so this is actually 3 to the 2x plus 2
power here we distribute the negative 3
this is 3 to the 6x minus 9 power now
you can see we have the same base so we
can set those exponents equal to each
other so we have 2x plus 2 equals 6x
minus 9 if we subtract 2x from both
sides that's going to give us 4x minus 9
equals 2 and if we add 9 to both sides
we've got 11 equals 4x and if we divide
both sides by 4 you can see that X is
equal to 11 fours and you got it now
sometimes you're probably saying Mario
but what if I can't get the basis to be
the same well then what you can do is
you can solve an equation such as this
an exponential equation using logarithms
and I'll show you how to do that in that
video right there we'll take a look at
that